I'm not an enforcer I'm more like a um a
fixer
exactly I have to convince a certain
person that the buddy in that trunk out
there is indeed Rolo something happened
to his
face what the it's missing along with
the rest of his
head betrayal is a funny thing it's very
naturous to catch you on a way
you ever heard a ring
doorbell we're under
attack st's
gone and you should be too I've always
had one rule s be good to the people who
were good to you be good to yourself
Charlie and get as far away from here as
you
can you turned on your own you ought to
get out of buuy Charlie that's what
everyone keeps telling me
that 50 Grand could really change things
for me I'm going with it without
[Music]
you ask Charlie I got more men than you
got bullets bullets are easy to
get what do you want you not breathing
and how you going to do that I'm doing
it were
you long you know you really ought to
start thinking about an Exit Plan
what are you waiting
for pull the trigger
[Music]
Charlie you're in over your
head I don't like loose
hands he was my second best guy I'm
looking forward to meeting number
one
long for a long
time